bonjour simon abi ramia merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu à emmanuel macron est arrivé
hier au liban pour rencontrer les
différents responsables politiques
quelle influence la france peut-elle
avoir sur le processus de réformes en
cours au liban écoutez face à
l'impuissance des dirigeants libanais de
provoquer ces réformes et pour répondre
aux attentes de la population libanaise
et vu les relations historiques qui
lient le liban à la france vous savez
que l'ibpt raté sous le mandat français
il ya des liens spécifiques entre les
deux pays je crois que la visite du
président macron le 6 août au liban a
créé un espoir et une dynamique
politique
ceci s'est avéré à travers la nomination
rapide d'un nouveau premier ministre
je crois que la france qui a de très
bonnes relations avec toutes les
composantes politiques libanaises peut
jouer un rôle positif en ce sens c'est à
dire pas pousser vers des réformes
politiques tant attendu par la
population aux libanaises justement vous
n'êtes de parler de la nomination du
nouveau premier ministre moustapha adib
est ce que la france a pu jouer un rôle
dans la nomination ce nouveau premier
ministre
oui vous savez généralement la
nomination d'un premier ministre apprend
beaucoup de longs mois au liban
cette fois ci ça a été fait sous une
dent dans une offre un jeu il ya eu 20
jours qui ont suffi pour qu'il ait cette
nomination ceci est dû sûrement à cette
pression permanente de la part des
autorités françaises le président macron
personnel en appeler pratique
pratiquement quotidiennement les leaders
politiques libanais le président
libanais pour les pousser à trouver un
non consensuelle et puis on a eu donc
avant-hier le nom de moustafa khatib
suite à des consultations entre les
anciens premiers ministres unite
parce que selon la constitution le
premier ministre et doit être sunnites
musulmans
donc effectivement la france a joué un
rôle en ce sens bien sûr il y a des gens
qui sont contents de cette nomination et
il voit cette nomination avec un certain
deuil un srec avec un certain bonheur
autre conteste comme on a pu voir dans
votre reportage vous l'avez dit una gran
accueil plutôt partagés dans la rue est
ce que vous avez eu l'occasion de parler
avec avec les citoyens comment peut il
accueille l'arrivée de ce nouveau
premier ministre au pouvoir
vous savez le liban vit et depuis le 17
octobre une forme de révolution donc
ceux qui manifestent dans la rue depuis
cette date là sont pratiquement contre
tout le système politique vous allez
entendre tout le temps un rejet de
chaque pas politique qui sera décidé au
pays par contre il y a des gens qui sont
plus pragmatiques et qui connaissent un
peu les rouages de la politique
libanaise et les subtilités du système
mais libanais savent qu'on est arrivé à
un compromis entre l'école les
différentes composantes politiques
libanaises qui ont abouti à la
nomination de mustapha dites moi même
j'ai nommé le nom de mustapha débit hier
lors des consultations parlementaires
avec le président de la république parce
que ils jouissaient de cette majorité
politique qui s'est traduite par
justement cette décision s'unit de le
nommer à la tête du gouvernement
libanais mustafa al dib a été nommé pour
prendre des décisions rapides afin de
faire sortir le liban de la crise selon
vous quelles vont-être ses premières
missions les missions les plus
importantes à réaliser pour pour lui
vous savez le liban vit dans une
situation économique catastrophique
un effondrement de la livre libanaise
une paupérisation delà de la khl delà de
la du peuple libanais 50% des libanais
se trouvent au chômage depuis le début
de la crise
donc avant tout il y a il y a le fait de
mettre sur les rails
si vous voulez une politique de sursaut
économique à travers les négociations
qui doivent être accélérées et trouver
une issue une issue rapide avec le fond
mais net monétaire international pour
pouvoir aider le liban
c'est la seule issue possible pour
sortir de la crise économique ça c'est
le premier volet le deuxième volet
effectivement celle attentes des
libanais ce sont des actes concrets
2 pour lutter contre la corruption et
plus de transparence dans le système
politique libanais et puis le troisième
volet je crois qu'il faut commencer à
débattre entre nous pour trouver un
nouveau système politique qui peut qui
peut passer le liban d'un état
complètement confessionnelles
communautaire un état un peu plus laïque
et je crois que c'est une revendication
de l'art de la rue libanaise
vous vous en parliez à l'instant c'est
le président aoun qu'il disait cette
semaine la volonté de faire du liban un
état laïque est ce que ça peut être
quelque chose de rapide ou est-ce que ça
va prendre du temps au liban ça ne peut
pas être rapide parce que on a un
système très ancré au niveau
confessionnelles et communautaire et la
religion pèse beaucoup au liban s'est
pratiquement l'appartenance religieuse
est pratiquement une identité politique
donc
mais bon on peut pas rester dans le
passé il faut vraiment regarder demain
et demain c'est la laïcité c'est la
citoyenneté
ce sont des notions qu'il faut commencer
à promouvoir au sein de la société
libanaise
et justement c'est le livre c'est le
nouveau liban le liban moderne j'espère
que les paroles que je suis en train de
prononcer trouveront effectivement écho
chez partout dans tous les partis
politiques parce que sinon le liban sera
voué à rester dans les carcans
communautaire et ne pourra jamais avancé
merci beaucoup
simon abi ramia d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin à sur arte france rappelle que
vous êtes député de la ville de jbeil du
parti courant patriotique libre proche
du président à aude merci beaucoup